in march basketball star rudy gobert
attempted to make light of concerns
about catching coronavirus
wiping his hands over the assembled
media's equipment
head coaches have gone back and you see
the teams heading back to the locker
room
two days later a game involving his utah
jazz team was called off at the last
minute
it later emerged gobert had become the
first nba player
to test positive for kovid 19. the teams
departed the scene
it would be more than four months before
they returned
the olympic flame continued to flicker
on even after most other sports had been
snuffed out
but at the end of march the decision was
taken to postpone the
2020 tokyo games by a year
they really have a cast iron
determination to deliver
a great games and yes they may be
slightly altered they may be
in a different format um
and who knows i mean we're still you
know we're still dealing with the
pandemic
even with a vaccine on the horizon but
i'm
pretty sure we will have a games
africa's biggest
sporting event the cub of nations was
pushed back a year
and the european football championship
will also start 12 months later than
intended
but the ambitious plan to host it across
12 different countries
is still in place for it's a big
challenge and
in times with pandemic and with this
strange situation even economic
situation next year will be a bit
tough maybe for for some parts of the
world or all the world
it will be a special challenge but you
know uefi is a serious organization we
like challenges
world cup host qatar became home to an
entire continent the asian champions
league took place
in the sort of biosecure environment all
athletes are getting used to
in england liverpool lifted the league
championship for the first time in 30
years
the supporters left to celebrate a
triumph they weren't allowed to witness
inside the stadium
innovation and commercial imperatives
have ensured short-term survival
but the financial and physical fallout
from the pandemic
is still tumbling through every level of
every sport
andy richardson al jazeera